you got it 2-1 yeah
[Music]
look I'll be honest I don't do Heights
very well but I also believe in tapping
your fears at head-on all right am i
clear you're clear whether it's
scrambling up a vertical inducing peak
or in some cases jumping into a deep
river high up from a bridge yep
this is what the face of sheer terror
looks like unfortunately for me when
you're so focused on the heights part
you forget one minor detail whatever you
do do not under any circumstances
let go of your rope
[Music]
[Music]
let me back up to a day ago and tell you
what I was doing jumping into a river to
begin with so I just got this in the
mail see what this is all about as I get
ready to go to Montana today to place
your National Park we have a Black
Diamond headlamp
I think these are GPS coordinates it's a
power bank and finally we have the
bigger one see what's in here
it's like a dry taupe bag so a few days
ago I had somebody from j-bird reach out
to me and invite me on this kind of
cryptic trip to Glacier National Park
the only thing I was told was that there
would be a live podcast there with rich
roll you know initially I had my
reservations and this was still when I
thought I was gonna do the AC 100 which
is coming up this Saturday today is
Tuesday of that week and through
Thursday was this Glacier National Park
trip so I had my reservations initially
but with AC out of the picture I was all
in thought it would be a great
opportunity to visit this beautiful park
this beautiful place in the world that I
haven't been to since I was in my early
20s and I was there for work at the time
so here we go Montana Glacier National
Park flying in to Kalispell going to be
three days of trail running and just
connecting with some really cool people
I would imagine so thank you so much
j-bird sports let's head to the airport
from there I bumped into rich roll and
his wife Julie at L a.m.
you man already after it we are going to
what part Glacier National Park Montana
I've never been three of us boarded a
direct flight into Kalispell Montana
[Music]
that boy Dustin how are you been good
just hanging out you excited yeah see
some bears and moose and whatever else a
few more people here at the moment hey
can I give you a hug
hi then rendezvous with a host of other
rat
the tents are really really cool down
there set up beautifully there's a whole
welcome kit so you'll see when you get
in that each tent is set up with some
really cool stuff as well there's our
new product and we're obviously
launching that's also on the bed I'm
Jeff Taylor with J burg sport we're here
celebrating the launch of our new Halo
product or truly Wireless Vista earbuds
the only reason that we were here what I
also learned what's that there are a lot
of really cool people in outdoor space
from runners to creatives to hikers to
be in the same spot as a handful of em
was really cool
and of course we had to get our water
[Music]
oh my god
after the run there was a little yoga
session led by Julie and then of course
there was the food incredibly delicious
spread by local chefs but really the
standout was definitely Julie's
plant-based cheese what she can create
without the use of a single drop of milk
is truly insane well what an incredible
day number one here in Glacier National
Park or we're actually about technically
15 minutes outside of Glacier National
Park today was just like half a day next
two days are gonna be amazing we're
gonna do it early early run tomorrow
which means like a 4:45 5:00 a.m.
wake-up call it is now 11:10 p.m. it was
really great to reconnect with old
friends
Timothy Olson rich Rahl and to finally
meet Justin Grunwald in person was
amazing he gave me this really cool
shirt in honor of Gabe which I will rock
proudly just a good vibe all around here
amazing people and I have to give a
shout out to Russell for putting all
this together including the help of
everyone at j-bird Sports amazing day
number one time for bed and I am excited
to share day number two tomorrow
[Music]
and so far Montana said incredible it's
a really amazing people amazing views
amazing floors amazing mountains amazing
Park basic food amazing food Britta way
to kick off the morning
okay morning our ventures are done now
its podcast time with rich roll I'm Gwen
Jorgensen and then after the podcasts
they have something cooking involving an
afternoon activity that they're not
specifying but is supposed to be fun so
I'm looking forward to that and let's go
check out the podcast
[Music]
after the podcast we got to take part in
a rafting trip for some breathing
exercises some team-building and of
course with general fund
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I think we're all caught up now an
ill-advised jump with my GoPro leading
it to sink 20 feet to the river's floor
with all the footage from the past
couple of days on it never to be seen
again
that is until Aquaman himself came to
the rescue
thanks for ritual the GoPro was found
returned to it's very grateful owner who
could do nothing more than sit there
with a stupid look of gratitude and
relief on my face anyway thanks to you
rich this episode was saved
back at the compound we shared one last
dinner together again courtesy of Julie
and the wonderful staff there
[Applause]
[Music]
and the following morning the entire
group head up Logan paths to climb
towards the top of Mount Overland a peak
topping out just above 80 100 feet an
unbelievably stunning trail complete
with mountain goats rams and beautiful
views play sure you're blowing me away
look at this place
still bananas
[Music]
guitarist
[Music]
[Music]
see that up there that's where we were
Oh finito
it really was the perfect bookend to a
wonderful three days in Montana that was
filled with adventure laughter all of it
heightened and made special by the
thought leaders and athletes at Cirque
Park
[Music]
so my sincere thanks to Russell and to
all the special folks at j-bird that was
involved with putting together this
unforgettable experience
until next time Montana
[Music]